1 2 3 en garde
car comment ils te vas le t-shirt attend
trop bien trop bien on voit bien
aujourd'hui 3 dvd des agents n'est que
trois mois ouais bah moi je suis invité
ni de ses quinze questions moi c'est
milla rêve tant à trois cartes ch'tis
vous devez chanter les gens du nord
aujourd'hui les gens du nord c'est vrai
qu'au bastia seraient infligées les
paroles les jambes du nord rendant dans
les yeux le temps qu'à l'heure des camps
légende huningue pendant le coeur le
saut est le soleil qui n'ont pas dehors
comme ça les gens oublient en occident
on veut toujours leurs portes à ceux qui
ont souffert les gens du nord n'oublie
pas qu'ils ont vécu des années dans